[Música]
en france 24 es momento de hablar de
ciencia y tecnología soy valentina torre
sánchez y es un gusto acompañarlos esta
vez desde casa a causa de la pandemia de
kobe 19 para iniciar vamos a conocer un
poco más de inspiration fue la primera
misión espacial con una tripulación
formada enteramente por civiles que
prepara la compañía spacex y que se
prevé despegue de la tierra durante el
último cuatrimestre de 2021 los cuatro
integrantes estarán en la órbita baja de
nuestro planeta en un viaje de unos
cinco días en los que se realizarán
experimentos científicos el comandante
de la misión será el empresario
tecnológico y piloto y ahorita hay
zachman creador de una de las
principales plataformas de pagos en
línea
he sido una entusiasta del espacio y de
la aviación desde que tengo memoria no
tengo miedo primero creo que ser el
comandante de esta misión es una
responsabilidad inmensa porque si vamos
a hacer que el espacio sea accesible
para gente común tenemos que lograr que
esta misión salga bien si no es así eso
retrasará el camino para todas las
personas que vengan detrás
pero la verdad estoy increíblemente
confiado en la tecnología de la que
space x es pionera
la misión es considerado un posible hito
porque marcaría el inicio de una nueva
era para la exploración y los viajes
espaciales justamente al abrir esta
selecta práctica a personas que no han
sido entrenadas profesionalmente para
ello el principal objetivo de esta
misión será recaudar fondos para el
hospital pediátricos en youtube que
trata a niños con cáncer y otras
enfermedades justamente por ello otra de
las tripulantes será el y arséne o una
joven de 29 años que en su infancia fue
tratada en ese centro de salud por
cáncer de huesos y ahora se desempeña
como asistente médica en el hospital con
este viaje hayley se convierte en la
estadounidense más joven en ir al
espacio
hasta ahora los astronautas tenían que
ser físicamente perfectos que no es una
categoría en la que yo entré por las
cirugías que tengo en mi pierna y eso me
emociona mucho sobre esta misión que
abre los viajes espaciales a todos
con mi papel en esto realmente espero
inspirar a pacientes que atraviesen su
tratamiento contra el cáncer
y a otros sobrevivientes porque todo es
posible
saben nunca pensé que iría al espacio y
me encantaría inspirar a mis pacientes a
soñar en grande y a no limitarse a los
otros dos tripulantes de la misión serán
elegidos al azar el tercer integrante
será una persona que haya donado dinero
al hospital y el cuarto un emprendedor
que haya utilizado el servicio de
procesamiento de pagos de aysa cuando
cambiamos de tema y vamos a francia
nació el primer bebé de un útero
transplantado en ese país
la madre de 36 años recibió el útero en
marzo de 2019 fue el primer trasplante
de ese tipo en el país y la donante que
hizo el procedimiento estando viva fue
su madre que en ese momento tenía 57
años
es un éxito o una culminación crea una
inmensa esperanza para decenas de miles
de pacientes
[Música]
pero el interés en esta investigación no
solo es el nacimiento sino también todo
el progreso en el campo de los
transplantes de útero y meetic y la
confrontación y turín la mujer se llama
devora inácio sin útero a causa del
síndrome de rokitansky una enfermedad
que afecta a una de cada cuatro mil 500
mujeres al nacer la bebé llegó al mundo
con un peso de 1.8 kilos tras 33 semanas
de gestación
los médicos de débora aseguran que este
procedimiento es una señal esperanzadora
para los pacientes que nacieron sin
útero o a las que se lo tuvieron que
extirpar y representa una alternativa
experimental a la adopción oa la
gestación subrogada que es prohibida en
francia
ella quiere tener otro embarazo
evaluaremos el estado del útero la
condición de la paciente los riesgos de
complicaciones en el futuro para
autorizar o no este segundo embarazo y
si todo sale bien podría volver a quedar
en embarazo después de un año o dos
dependiendo de lo que ella desee
vemos que el vídeo finalizamos este
espacio con la empresa btr robotics que
crear robots camareros que sirven comida
y retiran platos además de los lugares
tradicionales de venta de comida también
se utilizan en residencias de ancianos y
hospitales entre otros en estos momentos
la compañía opera principalmente en asia
pero está radicada en sillicon valley
donde también tiene varios robots que
sirven en las mesas de restaurantes se
han creado cinco versiones de estos
aparatos
la más reciente services que puede
llevar hasta 30 kilos y su batería dura
12 horas
la razón de un robot camarero es más un
transportador de comida la idea vino
para ayudar con la carga física y muchos
restaurantes y para facilitar la labor
de muchos trabajadores dentro de los
restaurantes porque muchos de ellos
tienen que recorrer largas distancias a
diario
así que en esencia lo que queremos es
alivianar la carga mediante la
automatización de la pandemia de kobe 19
ha hecho que se incremente la demanda de
estos aparatos porque gracias a ellos
los clientes pueden tomar su comida y
devolver los platos una vez que terminan
sin que haya contacto con humanos
la pandemia fue una sorpresa impactante
para todos incluidos nosotros tuvimos
que acelerar nuestra capacidad de
fabricación y de hecho pasamos una gran
parte del 2020 preparando nuestra
fábrica para producir robots de forma
masiva robots
llegamos al final de este espacio pero
recuerden que pueden ampliar toda la
información y repetir este y otros
programas en nuestra web france24
puntocom
más